[موسيقى]
انك تزرع وحدك العود وبعدين ينتج وبعتالي
تاكل الثمره متاعها معناها تفرح اللي انت
عملت حاجه بايدك واللي انت معناه انتجتها
وكليت الثمره بتاعها
[موسيقى]
عمر ثابت فلاح اصيل منطقه دوز ولايه قبلي
انا ما انسان مغروم بالفلاحه
عملت عده تجارب في
زراعه الورقيه انا جربت كل شيء من الخضر
اللي قاعده تجينا من
الولايات الولايات الوسط والجنوب وقت اللي
عرفت عرفت اللي تجربه نجحت بديت نزرع كل
عام
نخرجو للسوق
الحمد لله التجربه كانت ناجحه وهي اسبابها
الاكتفاء الذاتي
والبعد على المواد الكيماويه خاطر انا
نزرع بيولوجي نختنم الفرصه في اي منبر على
اساس تشجيع الشباب اللي يلزمهم يتجهوا
للفلاحه احنا كنا نتصوروا معنا برشا حاجات
ما تجيناش في الصحراء الصحراء قاحله ما
جاء فيها شيء لكن بالعكس كيف يبدا الماء
متوفر الحمد لله موجود كل شيء
[موسيقى]
قدم الماء موجود عنا في شيره نفزاوه حاليا
علاش ما معناها الذاتي في ولايه قبلي على
الاقل
واذا كان معناها نعمله مجهود اكبر نولوا
نصدره حتى للولايات الاخرى المجاوره علاش
تقريب حوالي اربع سنين ولا خمس سنين
معناها كل عام ننتجه في الخضره خضره معداء
الغبار فقط خضره موجوده معناها السوق ما
تبقاش بالعكس الناس تبدا توصي عليه يعني
السوق نتاعها موجود
طلب موجود طلب اكثر من الانتاج
[موسيقى]
احنا قبلنا نعرفو اهلنا معنا في الستينات
وفي السبعينات كانت النخله موجوده الخضره
تحتها الشجره البرقوق شجره الرمان شجره
التفاح كانت موجوده فهمتني ولكن الناس
امنت بعد ما ولت الدقله غاليه ولت ان
استخدم بركه الناس متجهه ومش حابب يعمل
الخضره تحتها رغم للماء موجود تحت النخله
بامكان يعمل شوي معدنوس شوي سلك على الاقل
اكتفاء الذاتي مش يبيع على الاقل هو
اللي كانت صحراء قاهله لكن بالعكس كيف
يبدا الماء متوفر الحمد لله موجود كل شيء
معناها بفضل الجهود والسواعد والخدمه بحول
الله كل شيء يجي نعرف برشا ناس عندها
اراضي شاشه وعندها المال حلو ولكن ما
تخدمش في الخضره انا نطلب منهم لو كان
معناه تشجعوا ويعملوا كده يعني على الاقل
نوصلو الاكتفاء الذاتي في ولايه قبلي على
الاقل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]